boy
what
a couple of people come here
well thank you all for coming
this is they call this the boot camp so
I suppose this is where we work you hard
and this is let me say a few practical
things first I've the last couple of
weeks I've been suffering from sciatica
pain in the back it's much better now
but standing for an hour might still be
a bit of a challenge so I've got myself
a chair as backup just in case I need to
sit down for a bit we so this is the
first lecture in a course on finite an
algorithmic model theory which as folk
Ian mentioned in the introductory
remarks is one of the four strands we
identified to focus on in in this
semester on logical structures and
computation which now logic and
computational spoken cell is a very wide
field we've picked out these four
strands I agreed to do a short course on
this one strand and of course preparing
it and discovered that this is a very
wide field I can't really do justice to
it in a short course what I hope to do
in the series of lectures is my focus is
on methods rather than results I want to
pick up certain methods that are
commonly used in the field a finite an
algorithmic model theory and illustrate
those methods by means a certain
illustrator illustrative results that's
the general pattern now I realize that
there are some people in this audience
who know more about the subject than I
do there are others who know perhaps
very little about subject to finite
model theory so it's addressing this
diverse audience i I mean I I hope I
mean there's some of you who will find
nothing that you don't already know in
the first couple of lectures but I hope
you know there you will find something
of interest as as things go on
some liked those preliminaries what is
this all about as I said I want to focus
on methods and essentially I think the
term finite model theory emerged in
about the 1980s I'll defer to folky on
who I mean I mean I asked for Kieran now
some time last year and I asked a few
other people who first used the term
finite model theory to describe this
subject but nobody seems to remember
anyway it came to be used as a term to
describe the study of the expressive
power of logic things like first order
logic second-order logic things in
between in the context of finite
structures the analogy being with the
study of model theory which is typically
has been concerned with issues of define
ability and expressive power in the
context of infinite structures the
analogy is loose because the methods
turned out turn out to be very different
and I mean the relationship with model
theory as classically understood is sort
of but tenuous at best the motivation
for studying finite model theory came
from computer science right I suppose
especially initially database theory and
complexity theory and the motivation is
essentially that many questions which
arise in the context of complexity
theory and database theory can naturally
be expressed as questions or understood
as questions about the expressive power
of certain logics and hence the need if
you will for developing tools for
analyzing expressive power now I said
I've said finite model Theory the title
is finite and algorithmic one proviso
here when we talk about the expressive
power of logics the ones the the the
kinds of questions that arise in in
these fields at least initially people
said back in the nineteen eighties
people said the structures involved in
computation are finite and therefore we
need to have specific tools for
analyzing expressive power in the
context of finite structures and the
tools from
it's a classical model theory simply
don't carry over so there's a wide range
of techniques many of them algorithmic
and we'll look at this and many of these
then extend beyond considering finite
structures to structures which may be
infinite but typically which have finite
or algorithmic description they can be
described by in some kind of formal way
through finite descriptions and so on
that's why we generally now talk a
finite and algorithmic model theory
there's a lot to be said on this but in
this course of lectures I'll go I will
generally stick to finite structures and
say very little about the extensions as
I said because I'm going to focus mainly
on the on techniques okay so what do we
mean what do I mean by model here any
questions questions about the expressive
power so typically we're kind of thing
we're saying is we have a formula and a
logic I'll make this all a little bit
formal in just a little bit and we asked
about its class of models say the class
of finite relational structures now
let's say this formula is in a in a
relational vocabulary has certain
relations and constants and so when I
talk about the models of fire I'll
typically mean the collection of finite
structures which satisfy here ok and we
want to ask essentially what classes of
structures are definable in this way
okay and I I say in a given logic L we
will start with say first-order logic
but then we'll consider variations of
this but this is the kind of define
ability question we are interested in oh
something's gone wrong here
I'm not even sure what that says now but
I'm sure it was nothing important so
formally a finite structure for us in a
relational vocabulary is a finite set
with some collection of relations on it
and some collection of constant symbols
so these constants are interpreted as
elements of the structure each of the
relation symbols comes with a Associated
arity as in it and is interpreted as a
relation of suitable arity on this
finite set more generally of course you
know you could consider function symbols
I'm not going to have function symbols
around in my vocabulary in general
simply because they make a lot of the
statements that I'm going to make a lot
more complicated to make but without
essentially changing them I mean there
are all essentially true in the presence
of function symbols just a lot more
complicated to say so I'll just leave
them out you can ask me that but about
that at the end of you if you'd like to
know more ok so when I say a property of
finite structures or classify no
structure I just mean any class of
finite structures closed under
isomorphism right so we we don't want to
distinguish between structures which
look the same so isomorphic structures
for our purposes are the same are
treated as the same and we're interested
in what we're in certain properties of
finite structures and we want to ask
questions like is a property definable
or indefinable so we ask for a given
logical for which properties P is there
acceptance in the logic which defines
exactly this property in other words the
structures that satisfy the sentence are
exactly the ones that have the property
P okay
that's our typical define ability or
undefinable any question so let's start
with first order logic simply because
this is I think something which most
people are familiar with and as an
example I mean we fix the vocabulary of
certain relations and constants so as an
example I'm going and this will be a
common running example I'll take through
this course fix the vocabulary let's say
with one binary relation and some number
of unity relations so this is already -
all of these are already one that I call
these things colored graphs you can
think of them as color directed graphs
right so you have a set we think of the
set of vertices a binary relation which
we think of is the edge relation it's
directed because I haven't specified
that it must be symmetric and we have
some number of urinary relations that I
think of them as colors on the vertices
of the of the graph possibly some
constant symbols occasionally I have
constant symbols for certain vertices
may have distinguished names that I can
use in my formulas and now I formulate
the first order logic through the
following rules we have terms any
constant by itself is a term any
variable by itself is a term and these
variables I think of as ranging over the
vertices of the graph we have we form
atomic formulas by saying that there's
an edge between t1 and t2 t1 and t2 are
terms I always assume we have equality
about so we can say two things are equal
and I can say that a certain sum key has
a particular color C I right so those
are formulas we close Emily use your
boolean operations and under first-order
quantifiers so these quantifiers in our
case we are ranging over the vertices of
a graph so I can say there exists an X
such that Phi and for all X such that
Phi ok so here's a I'll just write down
an example format of a kind of
computational problem that we might want
to express 6 a positive integer K and I
write for first order formula which
defines those graphs which contain a
vertex cover of size at most K
right so what does this vertex cover it
just says this right so there exists K
elements so is that for every y&z if
there's an edge between y&z then either
Y is one of the elements X I so that's a
big disjunction over all values of I or
is that is one of the elements X I so
right for every edge one of the
endpoints is in this set x1 to XK that's
what it means where K elements to be a
vertex cover and so this formula is true
when interpreted in a finite graph if
and only if the graph has a vertex cover
no more than K elements no more than K
because you can interpret some of these
variables by the same element so it's if
this can be satisfied by vertex cover
smaller than K okay so quantifiers range
over vertices of the graph
to pick another problem say we want to
say that graph is 3 colorable here we
can't do it and we'll see why we can't
do it as we go on we can't do it with
just a first order formula that is
formula in which the quantifiers range
over the vertices of the graph but we
allow ourselves quantification over sets
of vertices then we can say that a graph
is 3 colorable right so as you can see
okay and so there's just I mean it looks
like a mess but well it says the obvious
thing there are three sets of vertices
I've written V here but of course this
is well I should have left this out
there exist three sets are B and G I
just emphasized that they're sets of
vertices and every element is in one of
those sets no element is in two others
two of those sets and whenever you have
an edge the two endpoints are in
different sets okay so that says there
is a proper three coloring of the graph
right
now this is this slide is just a bit of
a nod to classical model theory I said
that you know a finite bottle theory at
least is named in reference to classical
model theory which studies the
expressive power of logics in the
context of infinite structures and most
of the methods available there are not
very helpful when we talk of finite
structures and I just wanted to mention
this the classical model Theory rests on
the foundations of two fundamental
theorems the compactness theorem and the
completeness theorem and they simply
don't tell us much when we restrict
ourselves to define I structures
compactness theorem fails in the obvious
sense that you can come come up with a
set of sentences every finite subset has
a model in the sense of a finite model
but the whole collection is
unsatisfiable
because it has no finite model that's
kind of trivial to write and a
completeness theorem fails in the strong
sense that the set of sentences
first-order sentence things are
first-order logic which are finitely
valid that is true in all finite
structures don't form a recursively
enumerable set so there is no sense in
which you can have a complete proof
system for the finite validities this
goes back to Trachtenberg I said these
are sort of the foundations of model
theory in the classical sense various
other things for example preservation
theorems of Bush tarski
and then fail when we restrict ourselves
to finite structures these are things
which tell us that first order logic
syntactic properties of first-order
formulas are closely related to semantic
closure properties of their models and
various file tree unlocks of other
foundational theorems also disappear so
the things on which classical model
theory is built the methods and the
techniques are simply not available for
the sorts of things we want to study
so what techniques do we have so the
class of finite structures in some sense
is not well behaved for the study of
define ability in the in the sense I
mean I remember back in the 90s having a
conversation about this with the John
bar wise and he said well the class of
finite structures is just not a natural
class why would you want to consider it
right but what I want to now tell you is
that certain there's a now a slew of
tools and methods to study expressive
power of logic in the finite but I'm
going to touch upon in this course and a
lot of these methods are essentially
computational algorithmic in nature one
which I'm going to start off with
focusing on in this lecture is iron
flash strikes a games or model
comparison games we'll see few
variations of these and this is sort of
a fundamental bedrock of analyzing the
expressive power of logic in the finite
it's just an in effect just a different
way of expressing when two things can't
be distinguished in in a certain logic
and then you know we we build other
tools on top of that in particular very
useful or locality theorems which I'll
review by the end of this lecture and
then I'll pick up on in in lecture three
to see some may be more sophisticated
sophisticated applications of these
there's a tomato-based methods for the
analysis of logic which will be the
focus of the next lecture tomorrow
complexity plays a big role I mean as
you can think of complexity I mean a lot
of the motivation of finite model theory
was to use model theoretic methods in
the study of complexity but of course
the reverse is probably even more true
using computational complexity as a way
of analyzing the expressive power of
logic has turned out to be very useful
and this will I say later lectures it'll
it's a strand that a weave through a lot
of what I have to say I think thought of
combinatorics I should have mentioned
Albert at serious will be giving a guest
lecture on Thursday as part of this
course and he will focus on that okay so
these are as I said I've picked out five
kind of thematic techniques that are
used for analyzing expressive power of
logics and this is how we sort of
structure the course okay so let's I'm
going to start and plunge in and talk
about our enforcer games and related
sorts of things so the key idea is
we have an equivalence relation and
structures of elementary equivalence
which says two structures are equivalent
if they cannot be distinguished by any
sentence of first order logic this is
again in classical model theory the
central well invert in some sense the
central object of study is this
equivalence relation you pick up a model
theory book like the one by Chiang and
Keesler and I say you pick a theorem at
random from the book and it will start
with let t be a complete theory which
really means pick one equivalence class
in this equivalence relation you take
the models of a complete theory there
are the therefore they form one
equivalence class and then you go on to
sort of say something about this on
finite structures this is an
uninteresting equivalence relation
because it's the same as isomorphism
those finite structures are elementary
equivalent if and only if they're
isomorphic and this is very easily seen
you start with the structure which has a
fixed number and of elements and you
write down a sentence which describes it
completely you say there exists n
elements and then you write a formula
with the variables x1 to xn which you
know having fixed a assignment x1 to xn
to the elements of a you just write down
the formula which says what things
what atomic formulas are true and false
of those assuming a finite relational
vocabulary here so you just say
everything there is to be said about the
structure and you say that every element
is one of them
ok and anything that satisfies this of
course is it looks exactly like it's
isomorphic to the way so anything that
satisfies the same sentences as a is
isomorphic to a
right anything that satisfies this
sentence is that some morphic to it so
Elementary equivalence is not very
interesting in the sense what we need to
understand what's going on here as I
said first order logic can make all the
distinctions that there are to be made
between finite structures that's what I
just said on the previous slide and so
any property what I called any property
of finite structures any isomorphism
closed class is defined by first order
theory okay you take any property
whatsoever
you take the sentences take the
structures which are not in s take the
sentence which characterizes it sticking
negation in front and take the set of
all of those anything that satisfies all
these sentences is necessarily in s and
so this theory this set of sentences
defines us exactly so classical model
theory being often in interested in the
expressive power of first-order series
you know that that sort of aspect
becomes uninteresting and Elementary
equivalence is the right tool for
analyzing the expressive power of of
theories if we want to understand the
expressive power of first-order
sentences in other words finite theories
finite collections of sentences we need
to consider equivalence relations that
are course within this okay Elementary
equivalence just makes too many
distinctions we want to make fewer
distinctions
I'm not just going to talk about the
expressive power of first-order
sentences I will also talk about logics
which go beyond first-order logic and
one way of understanding that is we're
looking we want to look at first order
theories other than the finitely excimer
Taizo but limited in some other way
right and they we think of those as
sentences in a logic more powerful than
force or logic look you can unfold them
into infinite for first-order theories
but there are sort of first-order
theories Ohio which are highly regular
in some way or the other okay and that's
what I say the monster studying Theory
satisfying a weaker axiomatic ability
requirement that finite maximize ability
they're not necessarily finitely
expertise but they'll be axiom
attachable in some way and we'll make
that precise okay so now I'm going to
talk about this limited understanding
the limits of expressive power
first-order sentences by considering
equivalence relations coarser than this
one
so first focus will be on the quantify
rank of a formula so we have a first
order formula the quantify rank is
simply the if you look at the formula
it's the maximum depth of nesting of
quantifiers inside the formula
I mean formally IIIi don't know that I
need to to go through this I think what
I said is enough for you to sit down and
write down formal definition right for
atomic formula zero boolean operations
you take the max and the quantifiers
increase the formula quantify rank by
one okay
I've already said this but maybe this is
a this is a good reminder I said there
are no function symbols and this is
really the the crux of the reason where
I said things would get complicated
we're going to use quantify rank as a
measure of the complexity of the formula
if we allow function symbols in our
vocabulary the nesting of functions
symbols inside each other
introduces a complexity which isn't
captured by this and we would have to
account for that separately effectively
functions and the nesting of functions
are a hidden form of quantify rank and
by by disallowing function symbols we
allows us to get a single measure which
is what we want that's really the reason
okay
with this proviso okay so now if we have
only relation and constant symbols then
in a finite vocabulary once you fix the
quantifier rank there are only finitely
many sentences you can write of that
quantifier rank this is a so again
crucially this is false if you have
function symbols because you can nest
the function symbols etc okay
there are only finitely many up to
logical equivalence this you can I mean
I can I think
leave it it's an easy exercise to prove
essentially you prove by induction you
prove this by induction simultaneously
for every M that the number of formulas
with M free variables is finite right
once you bound the point far right
that's the it's a kind of you need to
keep track of two things the number of
free variables in the quantifier rank
so now we say two structures are
equivalent up to P if they can't be
distinguished by any sentence of
quantifier rank it must be okay
using from from Q to P I thought I just
P throughout but okay and now this is in
some sense the right notion for
analyzing the expressive power for sorta
logic in the public sense if a class of
structures or some properties definable
by first order sentence it's closed
under this equivalence relation for some
P that's kind of obvious because the
first order sentence has some point of
higher rank P and so s must be invariant
under that P but the converse is true as
well
any property closed under this
equivalence relation for some P is
definable by first order sentence and
this follows from what I had on the
previous slide namely there are only
finitely many sentences of quantifier
and P up to equivalence so this thing
actually has finitely many equivalence
classes for every pair of them you can
find a sentence that distinguishes them
boolean combinations of those will
define every collection of equivalence
classes and that's that's all there is
to it
but we can see a bit more just like we
constructed for a Centon for a structure
a single sentence which describes it up
to isomorphism you can also construct a
single sentence which describes it up to
P equivalents okay
not again pretty much follows from the
fact that each equivalence class is
defined by a sentence which is what I
just said and that's that's this this Li
sentence which describes the equivalence
class of a I mean you can give an
explicit construction but but this is
enough for our purposes okay
I'm going to focus on this a little bit
and see how we can say something
meaningful about this equivalence
relation and deduce that certain things
are not definable in first order logic
right that's the VA now the essential
thing is these equivalence relations
have a nice characterization which is
first given by Fri say back in 1954 in
terms of sequences of partial
isomorphisms Aaron Feist gave a
description of this in terms of
two-player games which is nice and
prospectus and makes it makes it a very
useful tool so let me just explain what
it is partial isomorphism from A to B is
simply a injective partial function
which takes the interpretation of any
constant to the same constant in the
other structure and preserves all the
all the relations so whenever we have a
couple of elements away all of which are
in the domain of this function then that
is that tupple is in a relation on the
left if and only if it's image is in the
relation on the right okay so it's just
what you'd expect it's an isomorphism on
the domain of F with the requirement
that F is defined for all the constants
let's say
so what do we have so I'll give you the
game characterization of Aaron finished
the P round Aaron first game on
structures NB is as follows we have two
players we now call them spoiler and
duplicator and the idea is we have a
pair of structures a and B spoiler
claims that these structures are
different duplicator claims that they're
the same and they play a game to see
which one of them can establish their
claim and each round of the game spoiler
chooses one of the structures for
example be right and the the choice is
made at each round so you know different
rounds you could choose a different one
and I'm element of that structure call
it P sub I that I subscript I referring
to the round and duplicator has to
respond with an element of the other
structure and you look at after after P
rounds you look at the map which takes
the element chosen at the eye thrown in
a to the elements chosen at the i-raman
B along with the map on the constants
which is fixed anyway if this is a
partial isomorphism after P rounds then
duplicator has one spoiler has failed to
demonstrate a difference between them
but if it's not a partial isomorphism
spoiler has one spoiler has demonstrated
that the two structures are different
and the key thing that corrects this
with what we had before is that
duplicator has a winning strategy if and
only if the two structures are
equivalent so I mean this is not very
difficult to prove given the given what
we have already
so I mean I have on the next slide what
I call proof by example just to give you
the connection suppose and there's only
doing one direction of it suppose a and
B are not three equivalent means they
are distinguished by some sense of
quantifier rank three right and let's
say that sentences of the form that
exists X for all Y there is a sine theta
where theta is some formula involved in
those three variables and it's true in a
and falls in B so I want to say that
this sentence essentially describes a
strategy for spoiler to win the three
round game what's the strategy well
round one this existential is satisfied
in a and not in B therefore spoiler
chooses an element of a which satisfies
it the applicator has to respond with
some element of B necessarily this
element will not satisfy this
existential because he satisfies the
negation of that now whatever b1 chose
because of this universal this there
exists X for all Z naught theta is true
of b1 and so spoiler in the second round
chooses a witness for that existential
right so chooses a b2 which satisfies
for all that not be nor theta b1 b2
duplicator has to respond with an
element of a to okay necessarily because
of this universal there exists that
theta is true and so spoiler chooses a
witness for that said in a which
satisfies this and clearly duplicator
has lost okay you generalize this to
arbitrary first-order formulas and that
gives you one direction of this if and
only gives the other direction crucially
uses again the fact that we are in
relational vocabularies and we have
finitely many sentences Peter
next ye well is it obvious it is true
the strategy essentially exactly the
point is so what happens when you have a
conjunction or boolean combination of
formulas if you have a conjunction
that's true in one and false in the
other you just pick the conjunct that is
true and one and false in the other same
thing with these junctions and with
negation you'd sort of flip the roles of
the tube so but yeah but you're
absolutely right because putting it in
pre next normal form changes the
quantifier rank so so it is important
that we consider in in the other
formulas that are not in Phoenix normal
form so okay so as I said my example
shows one direction in fact that's
that's the direction of this that we
will be using right the direction that
says if the two things are distinguished
then spoiler has a winning strategy
right so in other words if duplicate it
does have a winning strategy then they
are indistinguishable so how do we use
this so we want to show that a class of
structure is not definable we have to
find for every P every positive integer
P a pair of structures which are
distinguished by this property s but not
distinguished by P colons in other words
we demonstrate that duplicator has a
winning strategy in the game in the P
round game played between these
structures okay so
I'll give you an example now
let's see em be a cycle of length n this
is a graph okay
so CN just denotes a cycle of length n
and now I considered two structures I'll
call it AP and BP and ap
is two cycles disjoint union of two
cycles each of size two raised to the
power P and B P is a single cycle of
size two raised to the power P plus one
okay
okay so I claim give you the argument on
the next slide but these two are P
equivalent so duplicator has a winning
strategy for p rounds of the game played
on these two structures
as an immediate consequence of this we
get for example two color abilities not
definable in first order logic ruff -
color ability because two color ability
is the same as the existence of a cycle
of odd length this graph has no cycles
of our length but this one does right
this is two colorable this is not so two
color abilities not definable in first
order logic having an even number of
elements is not definable in first order
logic simply because this graph has an
even number of elements in this one
doesn't write connectivity property of a
graph being connected is not definable
in first order logic because this graph
is connected and this one isn't okay so
all of these follow from this one
example so as I said you know they're
distinguished by these properties but
not distinguished for any fixed P we can
find a pair of structures which are not
distinguished okay so what is why is it
the D so to our P equivalent we have to
describe a strategy by duplicator and
I've summed up the strategy in these two
lines at the bottom though placated
strategy is to ensure that after our
moves of the game have been played we
have to maintain a partial arts
isomorphism for P moves remember so
duplicator strategy is that after our
moves have been played the elements that
have been picked in the two structures
their distance between them the graph
their existence is either equal or
bigger than to raise for P - ah okay so
the idea is spoiler picks an element to
placate a response with an element for
the first one it really doesn't make any
difference they're all interchangeable
now after some number of moves
you have
let's say these were three elements
picked three different rounds so and
these are the ones chosen by duplicator
in or these are the ones chosen and be
in response duplicator strategy is if
the distance between two elements is
bigger sorry is smaller then what's
happened here
it's smaller than to the p- are then the
distance over here is the same so if
this distance is small then this
distance is exactly the same as that but
if the distance is big like here it's
infinite then this distance is also big
bigger than 2 raised to the power of the
number of moves remaining and the idea
is that the best the spoiler can do to
force a win is pick something in the
middle to cut the distance in half and
duplicator can survive P rounds of that
okay that's that's the essential idea so
these two things are P equivalent and as
I said the undefined ability of all of
those properties follows
and I'll turn in a stratification we
will consider which will which is useful
in the study of fixed biologics I'm not
going to get to fix my logic Center
later but I thought I'd mentioned this
at this point is we say two structures a
and B are indistinguishable and I put
now I'm using superscript K I mean that
the country distinguished by any
sentence which use it at most K distinct
variables this is a very different
measure so let me sort of define it very
quickly so we write LK for the first
order formulas which use only the
variables x1 through XK so we fix the
set of K variables and those are the
only ones we are allowed to use in
constructing the formula another way of
thinking of this is this is those
formulas of first order logic in which
no sub formula contains more than K free
variables okay because if this is true
you can just rename the variables to use
just X 1 to XK by simple renaming you
will get a formula of L K ok so this is
a it's a it's a measure of the width of
a formula it's essentially says you
can't refer to simultaneously to more
than case things in inside your formula
ok now if two things can't be
distinguished by any formula for most K
variables they can't be distinguished by
any formula of quantify rank at most K
okay because any formative quantifier
any sentence I should say of quantifier
ranked at most K again can be rewritten
to use at most K variables right because
clearly if you have if it's a sentence
has no free variables and the quantifier
rank is at most K any sub formula
appears in the scope of it most K
quantifiers so it has at most K free
variables renaming variables you get
something in L K the converse is clearly
false in fact in a very strong sense you
for any P we can find two things that
are P equivalent but can be
distinguished by formula using just two
variables in fact this example will do
or some some version of that you might
have to make those graphs directed but
you can find a pair
which are indistinguishable in quite
frankly but distinguishable bias formula
using just two variables but high
quantify rank right you have to reuse
the variables in a clever way let me
give you an example so in particular
connectivity and to color ability even
for undirected graphs or axiomatically
okay okay but even having any the number
of n elements is not so those three
examples which I said this one showed
you first-order law you can't define
once we look at distinguishability in K
variables we get a difference between
them so let me see I down I tried to
write down in the definition in for
expository purposes I've used four
variables but you can get away with with
fewer a definition of connectivity right
so here's one for every L we can write
down a sentence sorry I sent a formula
with two free variables x and y using
only two additional variables which says
that there's a path from X to Y of
length less than or equal to L now L is
arbitrary but we're only using two
additional variables what do we say we
say there is an element set one and
there's X edge from X to Z 1 and is that
2 with an edge from Z 1 to Z 2 and we're
going to go on like this to say there
there's a sequence of L elements which
takes us to Y but the point is that once
we've said there's a Z 2 we can reuse
the variables at 1 because we don't need
it anymore
say there's a so X has a successor said
one which has the successors n 2 which
has a successor Z 1 which has a
successor Z 2 etc and L steps we then
say we get to why that should be minus 1
I suppose rather than I but write in L
steps we get to Y we've used total of
four variables for arbitrary hello now I
write a sentence which I've called
disconnect L which says the following
for every x and y if there is a path
from x to y of length at most L plus one
there is one of length at most L ok so
there's no pot no things in the graph
with distance greater than L but there
is a sorry that are in the
in where there is a path but if there is
a path effectively what this says is if
there is a path there's one of length at
most well but there is a pair of points
for which there's no path of length L
right so this describes graphs which are
disconnected but in which every pair of
points the same connected component have
distance at most L and now this infinite
collection of sentences which is the
negation of these for all L defines the
connected graphs right the graphs would
satisfy this for all values of L are
exactly the connected graphs and this is
a theory using as I've written it no
more than four variables okay but you
can't do it into a circle you can't do
it in first order logic
so I've already said this class of
structures is closed under P equivalence
for some P if and only if you define a
first-order sentence it's closed under K
equivalence if and only if it's
axiomatic over in L K possibly by an
infinite collection of sentences okay
because they're only finitely many
sentence of quantifier rank at most P
this equivalence relation only has
finitely many equivalence classes but on
the other hand the cake variable
equivalence classes already for K equals
2 and any larger values has infinitely
many equivalence classes ok I mean yeah
this is not very hard to construct the
examples I mean I say I made the claim
for K greater than 2 but you can take
the connected graphs example I had on
the previous one and certainly for K
equals 4 that already gives you examples
of this so this K variable equivalence
relation has a similar game
characterization we call this the
capable game again it's played by our
friend spoiler and duplicator playing on
a pair of structures a and B and the
idea is the following now we limit I
mean they this is to capture the idea
that in this cave variable logic
essentially you have to reuse variables
to be to say something meaningful so as
before spoiler and duplicator pick
elements of the structure but they have
limited resources we have K positions
they can point to it at any given time
and after that you can carry on the game
of beyond K moves but you have to move
the pointers so we call the pebbles so
and each move spoiler moves by picking a
pebble and placing it on an element of
one of the structures an element of a if
it's one of the a is an element of B if
it's one of the B eyes duplicator has to
take the corresponding matching pebble
and put it in the other structure and
again you look at the map defined by the
pebble elements if it's not a partial
isomorphism spoiler has demonstrated
that these two structures are different
and won the game and now you say if
duplicator has a winning strategy for p
moves then the two structures that we
are all said this is a file K of
quantifier ranked at most P and the key
point is P can be much bigger than K in
which case you will have moved pebbles
from one place to another during the
course of the game the number of rounds
you play for
can be much bigger than the number of
pebbles you use and I mean the I'm not
going to give a proof of this it's
essentially you just owe you you can
follow the lines along the lines of what
we had before I just say this the when I
mean what I've written over here is true
for infinite structures as well as
finite but if a and B are finite then
they're only finitely many possible
positions in the game and if you pick P
larger than the number of possible
positions and duplicator still has a
winning strategy that means duplicator
really has a winning strategy for
playing forever without ever getting
into a losing position so two structures
are K equivalent if and only if
duplicator has a winning strategy
forever this is specifically about
finite structures now right so if you
want to show that a classical structure
is not definable in first order logic
what we will typically do is for every K
NP we find a pair of structures one of
which has is in the class and the other
is not
and they're equivalent but because you
can always bound the number of variables
by the quantifier rank we usually just
forget about the K and that's what we
did before if we want to show that
something is not axiom atty scible with
a finite number of variables what we
need to show is for every K we can find
a pair of structures one of which has
the property and the other doesn't
and they're equivalent for all values of
P yes yes yes right so III didn't say
this but I use the word definable and
active advisable slightly differently in
that sense yes so when we want to show
that it's not xima ties well with a
finite number of variables this is that
this is what we typically show and here
as I said because when the structures
are finite to proving it off for our
peas it's enough to prove root for P
bigger than the size of the so let's say
the structure raised okay we actually
usually forget about the P and just say
we're showing the duplicated in play
forever
so here we can forget about the number
of variables here we can forget about
the corner if I rank usually okay that's
the way we use these things
something's gone wrong here as you can
see even as it's not recognizable we'll
find that number of variables because
for every K there structures where a key
has an even number of it right so I
showed you this example to show you that
connectivity to colorability and even s
the same with a single example are not
first order definable and I said
connectivity and to colorability
our axiom Eliza belay finite number of
variables but even there still isn't and
this is actually very simple you just
take any structure with K elements here
and I structure with K plus 1 elements
here no relations on the whatsoever ok
and the only relation is equality and
you see that duplicator has a strategy
for playing forever because you match
any move of spoiler on one side by
picking an element that's it well if
spoiler plays on an element that's
already pebbled you play on this
corresponding element on the other side
spoiler plays on an element that's not
currently pebble because there at most K
pebbles there is at least one on the
other side that's not pebble when you
place it there and all equalities are
always satisfied so duplicate ok just
carry on for forever ok
here's another example to make this a
little bit more interesting take the
complete bipartite graph on two sets of
key elements and this is the complete
bipartite graph with key elements and K
plus one elements okay for the special
case k equals three and the claim is now
again you play the K pebble game on this
and duplicator has a strategy for
playing forever because you match any
move of spoiler in this part with a move
on this part and vice versa any move on
this part with a move on this part of
that and vice versa because they're more
than k in each part e qualities will
always be satisfied you can always find
an element not equal or equal to the
others as necessary and between the
parts there's always an edge so that's
also satisfied so what can we say these
two things are equivalent but this graph
has a perfect matching and this one
doesn't
therefore the property of having a graph
having a perfect matching is not
Aksumite eyes'll with any finite number
of variables it also turns out that this
graph has a Hamiltonian cycle and this
one doesn't right because you can
there's your Hamiltonian cycle to see
that this one doesn't notice that each
stage of the cycle you have to cross
from one part to the other and since
there's more out more elements on this
side than that
you can't do that without repeating
vertex right if you if you're going to
visit everyone so the property of having
a Hamiltonian cycle is not axiom a
terrible with a finite number of
variables okay
now let's see Visser 12 right so I'm
gonna come back to the uses of these
finite variable logics later I just
wanted to say a little bit about as I
said I wanted to get to talking about
locality and this will be the last thing
I'll say to define what I mean by
locality it's useful to define given a
structure we define a graph which
relates two elements so we put an edge
in between two elements if there is some
relation in the structure which contains
a tuple containing both elements okay so
basically two things are related somehow
by the structure we call this the guys
man graph of a right you take the
universe of a along with this edge
relation which is a symmetric edge
relation so it's an undirected graph and
when I say when I talk of the distance
between two points in the structure I
mean the distance in this graph the
graph theoretic distance
and I will talk of the neighborhood of
an element a this means you take all the
elements neighbourhood up to a radius
hour for positive integer you take all
the elements at distance at most are to
a and you look at the substructure they
induce okay so this is a structure in
the vocabulary of hey okay I call this
the not our neighborhood of the single
element this allows me to formulate my
first version of the huns locality here
which is the following we say two
structures are hand for covalent with
radius R if the following is so I mean
realize this maybe not the most clearest
formulation of this but I put it in this
form because I'm going to introduce
thresholds later and it's easier to do
it this this way let me give you the
clearer formulation so things are hard
for covalent with radius R if there's a
bisection between the two universes pew
in the two structures says that for each
element the it's our neighborhood is
isomorphic to the RN neighborhood of its
image what I've written here is there
are an equivalent if you count the
number of isomorphic neighborhoods for
each element and you count the number of
elements which have isomorphic
neighborhoods to a in B they have the
same cardinality so you can put the
bisection between them and the same for
B so for each element of B you count the
number of neighborhoods in a which have
the same which are isomorphic and you
count the number of neighborhoods and B
which are isomorphic and they have the
same they have the same number of
elements
at the beginning a priming
and yes this wonder there's something
happily thank you yes okay and the hands
locality theorem says
Fredi vocabulary and NEP you can find a
radius R and at most three to the p3 to
the B's enough so that if a and B are
hands equivalent up to alias R then
they're not distinguishable in where for
any first-order sentence of quantifier
rank it must be so if the neighborhoods
up to a fixed radius the kind the the
you look at the multi set of
neighborhoods that appears in a and it
is the same as the multi set of
neighborhoods that appear in B but you
can't distinguish them alright so first
order logic really talks about local
neighborhoods is what this is saying
right now and five minutes I think I can
sketch you a proof of this and that'll
be a good point to stop them so what's
the what's the proof the a the idea is
we want similarly for every B means the
symmetric bit right okay so
yes this is not the best formulation as
I said that's why I said it's it's the
existence of up by ejections which is a
bit clear okay so let me I want to give
you the idea of proving this the idea is
of course we start from this assumption
and we want to show that from that we
can construct a winning strategy for
duplicator in the P round game the
applicator strategy will be to maintain
the following condition so you have the
structure and you have the structure B
and in here you have elements a 1 a 2 a
3 right over here you have elements b1
b2 b3 which have been selected in
previous rounds and what you do is you
take the name neighborhood
radius up to 3 raised to the power of
the number of moves remaining to play
around these points and you take the
union of these neighborhoods and you
have the same in B and duplicator
strategy is to maintain an isomorphism
between these two sets between these two
sub structures I should say okay why is
this possible
well for the first move it's just
follows from the definition right you
pick one you look at the neighborhood of
radius three to the P there must be one
on the other side with an isomorphic
neighborhood now we want to so
inductively this remains true so suppose
now spoiler picks an element let's say
somewhere in the structure and we
consider two cases either it is so what
are we going to do at the next move
we're going to shrink the radius of
these neighborhoods but then we're
adding one at one additional element and
we want to do the same on the other side
while keeping an isomorphism suppose
this element this spoiler chooses
is
2 times 3 raised to the power of the new
right so 2 times 3 to the P minus K
minus 1 means 2/3 of this radius that
I've drawn before if it's within 2/3 of
that radius that means it's neighborhood
of radius 3 to the P minus K minus 1 is
entirely within this and therefore by
the isomorphism there's an element here
B whose neighborhood well it'll be sorry
and it'll be entirely within this you
know and because there's an isomorphism
between these whole substructures you
pick the image under that and you know
what happens if you pick an element here
which whose distance from any previously
chosen element it's bigger than that
well that means that when you shrink the
size of the neighborhoods by a factor of
3 its neighborhood of radius 3 to the P
minus K minus 1 will be disjoint from
all of these ok and that means just by a
count of the neighborhoods there must
exist a B on the other side whose
neighborhood of radius 3 to the P minus
K minus 1 looks exactly like the
neighborhood of a and you pick that and
it's disjoint from every this unit from
this structure you had before okay
that's the essential idea it kind of if
you if you look at it it's a great
generalization of this construction keep
things far apart things that are far
apart you can't spoil it'll take a lot
of moves for spoiler to show that they
are actually different right and things
that are close you keep isomorphic
that's duplicator strategy ok
okay so that's and we're going to look
at certain applications of this and uh
and of the other locality theorem
grassman locality which I haven't got to
but I think I'll stop at this point and
next time we look at some applications
of locality and also at automata theory
methods
more questions it's a question but on
your accounting condition for
hospitality you actually with your
statement on the previous screen was
what counts for equal and yes but
actually all you need them to be bigger
than K certain thresholds that's what
that and I will I will use that later
and where I was going I that's what I
said this looks unnatural the natural
weight would need to say simply there's
a bi ejection between a and B but I
stayed with it in this form because
later on I'm going to add a threshold to
it doing exactly what exactly exactly
yeah okay any other questions okay you
know what we don't have locality
that's when we'd actually don't know how
to use so when we have arbitrary built
in structures into the we should be able
to use these characterizations in order
to yes yeah so III I think the point
that I've got right so I mean this is a
locality theorem is true in general but
the trouble is that in many interesting
structures the neighborhood of a single
element maybe the whole structure and
then this doesn't tell you anything
interesting because it's just saying if
the two things are isomorphic hmm for
example if your structure is linearly
ordered for instance yes
so that's that's exactly right maybe you
want to point out that it's true in
general for finite structures right I
mean this is not true as stated for
infinite structures unlike all the other
game theoretic things you
sorry which bit is not true well that
you get elementary indistinguishability
foodie no I mean I'm only coming
claiming P indistinguishability okay
yeah okay
let's talk in the break all right 1:30
okay